eigentlich kommen nur ein pensionierter
fachhochschulprofessor aus schwalbach im
taunus doch ihm ist eine mathematische
sensation gelungen
und wenn er nicht einen kleinen trick
angewandt hätte müssten wir heute noch
nichts von seiner entdeckung über eine
mathematik kollegen von den
universitäten hatten ihn nämlich nie so
richtig anerkannt herzlich willkommen
bei tricks und sandwichs
die mathematik ist schon eine seltsame
wissenschafter gibt es momente die
einfach nur wunderschöne gebilde
produzieren oder gleichungen die logisch
einfach aber nicht zu beweisen scheinen
wie diese die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
beispielsweise ein pfeil zwei
überlappende flächen gleichzeitig trifft
ist größer gleich dem produkt der
wahrscheinlichkeiten nur eine der
flächen zu treffen
es geht hier um sich überlappende
symmetrische flächen die entweder beide
gleichzeitig getroffen werden können
oder eben nur eine von beiden das ganze
nennt sich aus zur korrelation zum
gleichung und die formel seit ein paar
tagen über google zu finden weil sie bis
dato niemand interessiert hat außer
mathematiker bis dato bis vor wenigen
tagen schuld daran ist ein mathematiker
aus schwalbach im taunus der morgens
beim zähneputzen eine idee hatte thomas
rauen er war fachhochschulprofessor ist
mit 67 jahren in kissing schon in rente
das problem um das es geht betrifft zwei
flächen beziehungsweise mit ihnen ist es
am einfachsten zu erklären es geht um
die wahrscheinlichkeit wie beide zu
treffen
praktisch angewendet wieder so aus ich
habe hier zwei flächen ein kreis und ein
rechteck also zwei will metro flächen
beide überlappen sich jetzt gibt es eine
gewisse wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich die
mitte treffe wenn ich darauf viele die
mitte wird immer öfter getroffen als der
randbereiche ist ja auch logisch ich
viele jahre darauf erkennt das
wahrscheinlich das ist die gaußsche
glockenkurve benannt nach dem berühmten
deutschen mathematiker carl friedrich
gauß eine seiten der kurve sind die
wenigen treffer im außenbereich und in
der mitte die vielen treffer im zentrum
jetzt haben wir bei diesen beiden
flächen zwei glocken kurven eine für den
kreis und eine für das rechteck das
besagt die gasse korrelation zum
gleichung dass die wahrscheinlichkeit
beide flächen zu treffen
mindestens genau so hoch ist wie die
wahrscheinlichkeit den kreis zu treffen
x der wahrscheinlichkeit das rechteck zu
treffen
die gleichung kombiniert quasi die
beiden glocken kopf nimmt er also anders
die wahrscheinlichkeit den kreis zu
treffen bei 0,8 und die
wahrscheinlichkeit das rechteck zu
treffen
bei 0,9 liter liegt die
wahrscheinlichkeit weile zusammen zu
treffen bei 09 08 also bei 72 das ist
die wahrscheinlichkeit
mit der ich mindestens weideflächen
gleichzeitig mit den nächsten wurf
rapper unter diesem wert und das besagt
die formel kann die wahrscheinlichkeit
weideflächen zu treffen nicht sinken
so weit so gut aber wie beweist man auf
mathematiker rund um die welt haben sich
jahrzehnte daran die zähne ausgebissen
thomas rollen aber hatte eine wichtige
vorarbeit geleistet er hatte sich schon
länger mit dem problem der ski quadrat
verteilung gefasst und beim zähneputzen
am 17 juni 2014 kam ihnen die
entscheidende idee die dabei
entwickelten methoden können er
vielleicht benutzen um die gäste
korrelation zum gleichung zu bereiten
sofort machte er sich an die arbeit und
hatte sie bereits abends in groben zügen
gelöst
aber dann kam der kasus knaxus nur
selten wurden seine arbeiten
veröffentlicht seine kollegen von den
richtigen universitäten nahmen ihn nicht
ernst oft wurden arbeiten gar nicht
veröffentlicht weil so die vermutung die
gar nicht gelesen oder beim schnellen
drüberfliegen nicht verstanden worden
das sollte mit diesen beweis nicht
passieren jetzt kann der entscheidende
trick thomas freuen entschied sich seine
arbeit nicht irgendwo sondern im und
jetzt kommt's indischen sonal fahrer ist
joel vorzeitige statistics zu
veröffentlichen also dimensional für
theoretische statistik des fernen ostens
das ist einfach genial damit hat er
seine hochnäsigen mathematiker kollegen
einfach mal rechts überholt damit war
der beweis in der welt und verdiente rom
thomas freuen sich am eine verbeugung
und mein höchster respekt vor dieser
arbeit und dem weg den er für die
veröffentlichung gewählt hat herzlichen
glückwunsch stoffers freuen wenn ihr
mehr solcher ja wissenschaftlicher kind
sehen wollt dann solltet ihr hier ein
abo aufs auge einfach draufklicken und
vergesslich dann noch eine auf die
glocke zu geben solche videos gibt es
hier ja jeden tag also bis dahin bleibt
dran